and we have another great show on the
way from an iconic stage the
international showroom at the west gate
las vegas it's been home to some of the
greats and heather mills is backstage
with zoe bowie right now check it out
for more than 50 years this has been one
of the most iconic stages in las vegas
and an international superstar helped
kick it off elvis presley now called the
westgate las vegas it opened as the
international in 1969. elvis sold out
636 shows in his seven years here since
then other iconic performers have graced
the stage including barry manilow wayne
newton
to liberace and next
zoe bowie
here we are we're backstage this is an
iconic room i i mean the king used to
sit here how cool is that to sit at this
bar that elvis is what's that well i'll
tell you i i think i speak for a lot of
certainly male entertainers or anybody
that's ever held a microphone
can go back to these recordings of elvis
presley
live from las vegas in this very hotel
on the stage that's right upstairs
and that was so influential to me
personally listening to these records
and dreaming of what his life may have
been in las vegas specifically
and
decades later to be sitting here
at his bar ready to go up on his stage
performing even some of his music
is is not just a dream come true for me
but i think hopefully i i hope that
there's a lot of people that can live by
curiously
through how excited i am tonight is kind
of a culmination of years and years of
dreams
coming to a head on new year's eve
on this stage doing what i love best and
so i hope everybody's ready to have darn
good time have a couple cocktails and
celebrate 2022. well cheers to that what
can they expect from you on stage what
are you going to give them tonight that
they might not see any other time well
uh
we're trying to take a little
combination of
everything that is las vegas
we're going to do some music that to me
is kind of the soundtrack of the city
and we're going to do some music that is
uh
hot on the charts with the kids and
we're going to combine it all together
we're going to give it a little vegas
spin
that little sound that is synonymous
with this
i town zoey boy coming up in a minute
bro